PROFESSOR: The story
begins with a statement
that we will verify to some
degree in the homework that
is due on Wednesday
of vector operators.
This operator Sz,
the one-line summary
is that this
operator is a vector
operator under
angular momentum--
under the total
angular momentum.
And as such, its matrix
elements will behave
like the matrix elements of Jz.
So how is that true?
What does it mean to say that
S is a vector operator under J?
It is to say that for
J, S is like a vector.
And that is a concrete
statement that you
should check whether it's true.
The statement is that Ji Sj--
here, this i and j
run from 1 to 3--
is equal to ih bar
epsilon ijk Sk.
That is the statement that
S is a vector operator.
You may have seen this
in a previous course,
in 805, where you might have
proven that X and P are vector
operators for L.
And here, the proof
is not all that
difficult. In fact,
it's almost obvious
this is true, isn't it?
Ji is Li plus Si.
Li doesn't talk to Sj.
But Si with Sj satisfy the
algebra of angular momentum
that is precisely this one.
So this is almost
no calculation.
You will check-- you'll
remind yourself--
that if you have a
vector, that L-- for L--
X and P are vector operators.
So for example, Li Pj is
ih bar epsilon ijk Pk.
And this, you do by
calculating the commutator.
But after you calculate
the commutator a few times,
it's better to just remember,
oh, it's a vector operator.
That's a good way of
thinking about this.
OK.
If you have vector
operators, they
have very peculiar
properties sometimes.
One that may sound a
little unmotivated,
but it's very useful,
is the following.
Suppose you form the double
commutator of J squared
with the vector operator S.
Here, you will find an identity.
And to make it fun for
you, I will not tell you
the number that appears here.
It's some number.
But with some
number here, this is
identical to the following
SJ times J minus 1/2
J squared S plus SJ squared.
Well, it's important to
look at this equation,
even to make sure
everything is in order.
This is a vector equation,
so it's three equations.
So J squared, despite all
this arrow, is a scalar,
has no indices.
It's J1 squared plus J2
squared plus J3 squared.
S, on the other hand, has
an arrow, and it's a vector.
So you could look
at this equation
for the third component,
for the first component,
for the second.
So here is a vector,
the three things.
Here is also a vector.
It's S dot J and J.
So the vector index
is carried by the J here.
The vector index is
carried by S here--
once to the left of J squared,
once to the right of J squared.
Also, maybe you
should notice that SJ
is the same thing as JS, not
because these operators commute
but because SX and JX commute.
Sy and Jy commute.
And Sz and Jz commute.
Different components
would not commute.
But here, these ones do commute.
So this is a formula you
will show by computation.
I don't think there's a simple
way to derive this formula.
But it's true and
false by computation.
This formula implies a
result that is quite pretty.
It's sometimes called
a projection lemma.
So all we're doing is trying
to compute a matrix element,
and we're forced to
consider a lot of structure.
We're just trying to
show this simple matrix
element, with an Sz here,
is proportional to mj.
This is our goal.
And we're going to do that.
So suppose you take that
interesting equation
and find its expectation
value on a state that
is an eigenstate of j.
So suppose you take a j mj and
put this whole equation inside
this-- left-hand side,
then right-hand side--
a state that is an
eigenstate of j.
Now, that state may be an
eigenstate of other operators,
as well.
It doesn't matter.
Now, look at your
left-hand side.
It's a commutator.
You have a j squared on
the left, a commutator
on the right minus
commutator on the left, j
squared on the right.
In both cases, there will be
either a j squared near the bra
or a j squared near the ket.
Those two terms come
with opposite signs.
Since those are eigenstates with
the same eigenvalues, that's
what we're doing-- an
expectation value here,
the left-hand side is 0.
So the left-hand side
contributes nothing.
So left-hand side is
0, on this thing, is 0.
And let's look at
the right-hand side.
It's equal to j mj S
dot J J jmj and minus--
so that was the first term.
Now, we have to compute this
thing on this Jm Jm state.
Again, a J squared is either
to the left or to the right.
Therefore, this
gives a number which
is h squared j times j plus 1.
This gives the same number,
as I showed you, on the bra.
You have two terms.
The factor of 1/2 cancels.
And you're left just with the
expectation value of S, which
is kind of what we wanted here.
So this is minus h
squared j times j
plus 1, which is the
expectation value of J
squared times the expectation
value jmj of S on the jmj.
OK.
You have this term minus
that term equal to 0.
So what have we learned?
We have learned that this term
that we can call expectation
value of S vector
on a j eigenstate
is equal to the expectation
value of this quantity,
S dot J J on the eigenstate
divided by this number, which
turns out to be the
expectation value of J
squared on that eigenstate.
This formula looks like a
projection formula in which you
say the expectation value
of S is the expectation
value of the projection of
the vectored S onto the vector
J. Remember, if you have,
for example, projection
of a vector a into
a unit vector n,
what is the projection of a
vector a into a unit vector n?
Well, the projection
is a dot n times n.
That's the component of
a along the vector n.
But if n is not a unit vector,
the projection of a along b
is a dot b times
b over b squared.
Because, in fact, the
projection along a vector
or along a unit vector
is the same thing.
It's just a projection.
And here, you have unit vectors.
So this is the projection lemma.
It's a very nice result--
pretty striking, in fact.
This result is also
mentioned in Griffiths.
It doesn't give a derivation of
this result. It's just quoted.
But it's a beautiful
and important result.
It's conceptually interesting.
It's valid for any
vector operator under J.
And this will
answer our question.
Because now, we can
use this formula
to compute the matrix element.
So what do we have for our case?
We have that nljmj
Sz nljmj is what?
Well, we have the expectation
value of Jz on this state.
So it's going to
be h bar mj over h
squared j times j plus 1.
That's the denominator.
And you still have here what
may look like a small challenge,
or a big challenge--
happily, it's a small challenge.
S dot L mljmj.
Here, this is called
the scalar operator.
This is a variant
on the rotations.
And scalar operators
are independent of mj.
We got the mj dependence here.
We want to claim
that this expectation
value is proportional to mj.
And we have the result here,
unless there is mj dependence
here.
But there is no mj dependence
here because, as I said,
this has to do with the fact
that this is a scalar operator.
So let's calculate this part to
finish this whole computation.
How do you do that?
Well, you have to remember
you have J equal to L plus S.
So in here, we'll
do the following.
I'm sorry.
I had the confusion here.
S dot J-- it's S dot J here.
It's starting to look wrong.
So I mean the dot
product of J and S.
So here, I'll take l
equals to J minus S.
And L squared is equal to
J squared plus S squared
minus 2S dot J.
Here, it's important
that S dot J and J
dot S are the same.
And therefore, this S dot J is
1/2 of J squared plus S squared
minus L squared.
So with S dot J being
this, you see immediately
what is this number.
This is h bar mj h
squared j times j plus 1.
And now, 1/2-- so I have a 1/2
here, I'll put it in front--
J squared-- so this
is j times j plus 1,
there's an h squared
that's in addition--
h squared here--
j times j plus 1
S squared, which
is 3/4, for it's
been 1/2, minus L squared,
which is minus l times l plus 1.
OK, almost there.
Wow, this takes time.
But we have a result.
So what is the result?
The matrix element nljmj lz--
oops, I'll put the whole
thing together-- lz plus 2Sz--
back to the whole
matrix element.
Remember, we had one piece--
hmj and, now, this part.
So adding the hmj
to this new part,
we have hmj 1 plus j times
j plus 1 minus l times l
plus 1 plus 3/4 over
2j times j plus 1.
Phew.
OK.
I'm sorry.
It's all here.
I just copied that term,
hopefully without mistakes.
So we have our matrix element.
And that matrix element
in the top blackboard
there gives us the splitting.
It's probably a good time
to introduce notation.
And there's a
notation here where
this is called g sub J of l.
And it's called
the Landé g-factor.
It's a g-factor in the sense
that affects the energy
levels as if you were
modifying the magnetic moment
of the particle.
So this number tells
you how the level split.
They split proportional to mj--
all the various levels.
And for the full
multiplate, the multiplate
is an eigenstate of j
and an eigenstate of l.
So throughout all the
states in the multiplate,
this is a single number.
And just, you have the hmj.
End result is the
weak Zeeman splitting
nljm is eh bar over 2mc times
B times gJ of l times mj.
And this number is
about 579 times 10
to the minus 9 eV per Gauss.
It's small.
So wow.
It took us some effort.
But here we are.
We have the weak-field Zeeman
splitting completely computed.